mr speaker
mr speaker with your with your
permission i'll make a statement on uh
the omicron variant and our measures to
contain this virus
fortify our nhs and keep our country
open
first i'm sure the whole house will join
me in paying tribute to everyone working
in our nhs and social care
for their extraordinary efforts in the
teeth of yet another way of this
pandemic and for all they've done
together with thousands of volunteers to
get britain boosted
since we began the get boosted now
campaign just over three weeks ago we've
delivered 10 million extra boosters
across the uk
we've doubled the rate of vaccination
from 450 000 doses a day to a peak of
more than 900 000
we've matched the nhs's previous record
day and then beaten it again and again
and we've met our target of offering a
booster to every eligible adult in
england a whole month early as a result
we have a higher level of booster
protection than all our european
neighbors with over 34 million boosted
administered across the uk including in
england reaching more than 90 percent of
the over 70s and 86
of the over 50s
together with the evidence that omicron
causes less severe disease than previous
variants and the way the public have
conscientiously changed their behavior
in response to plan b this level of
protection means we're in a very
different position than during previous
waves
i know some honourable members might
therefore ask whether this means we can
now do away with measures altogether but
i'm sorry to report that hospital
admissions are rising rapidly doubling
around every nine days with already more
than 15 000 coveted patients in hospital
in england alone
we're experiencing the fastest growth in
covid cases we've ever known with over
200 with over 218 000 cases reported
yesterday uh although uh that includes
some uh that included some delayed
reporting
and potentially of greatest concern case
rates are now rising rapidly among the
older and more vulnerable including
doubling every week among those over 60
with the obvious risk that this will
continue to increase the pressures on
our nhs
so in response to the latest data the
cabinet agreed this morning that we
should stick with plan b for another
three weeks with a further review before
the regulations expire on the 26th of
january
people in england should carry on
working from home whenever they can wear
face coverings on public transport and
in most indoor public places and take a
test before going to high risk venues or
meeting the elderly or vulnerable
all of these measures are helping to
take the edge off the omicron wave slow
the spread of infection manage the
immediate pressures on our nhs and buy
time for the boosters to take effect
and those in scotland wales and northern
ireland should of course continue to
follow the rules where they live
mr speaker faced with these pressures on
our nhs i know some members may ask the
opposite question whether we should go
even further and move towards a full
lockdown
the lockdowns are not cost free they
impose a devastating toll on our
physical and mental well-being on our
businesses jobs and livelihoods and
worst of all on the life chances of our
children so this government does not
believe we need to shut down our country
again
instead we are taking a balanced
approach using the protection of the
boosters and the plan b measures to
reduce the spread of the virus while
acting to strengthen our nhs protect
critical national services and keep our
supply chains open we're building on
site nightingale hospitals and creating
2500 virtual beds to increase nhs
capacity we've bought more antivirals
per person than anywhere else in europe
and we're now working to identify those
trusts which are most likely to need
military support so this can be prepared
now
from the 10th of january we will provide
100 000 critical workers in england with
free lateral flow tests for every
working day to help keep essential
services running this includes those who
work on critical national infrastructure
national security transport and food
distribution and processing and these
tests are separate and in addition to
those already allocated to our public
services such as in education where we
have delivered 31 million testing tests
testing kits to schools and colleges for
the start of the new term mr speaker we
have the biggest testing program in
europe registering almost twice as many
tests as france and four times as many
as germany
last month alone we distributed 300
million natural flow devices enabling
millions of people to get taste tested
and keep their loved ones friends and
colleagues safe in the run-up to
christmas but thanks to the sheer size
of the omicron wave we still need to
take steps to ensure our testing
capacity reaches those who need it most
so we will be suspending the need to do
a pcr to confirm the result of a
positive lateral flow test from next
tuesday in england if you test positive
on a lateral flow device you should just
record that result on gov dot uk and
begin self-isolating mr speaker our
balanced approach also means that where
specific measures are no longer serving
their purpose they will be dropped so
when the omicron variant was first
identified we rightly introduced travel
restrictions to slow its arrival in our
country
but now omicron is so prevalent these
measures are having limited impact on
the growth in cases while continuing to
pose significant costs to our travel
industry so i can announce it in england
from 4 am on friday we will be scrapping
the pre-departure test which discourages
many from traveling for fear of being
trapped overseas and incurring
significant extra expense we will also
be lifting the requirement to
self-isolate on arrival until receipt of
a negative pcr returning instead to the
system we had in october last year where
those arriving in england will need to
take a lateral flow test no later than
the end of day two and if positive a
further pcr test to help us identify any
new variants at the border
mr speaker all these measures are
balanced and proportionate ways of
ensuring we can live with kovid without
letting our guard down and we can only
do this thanks to the biggest and
fastest booster campaign in europe yet
mr speaker there are still almost nine
million people eligible who have not had
their booster as many as 90 percent of
those in intensive care with kobe have
not had their booster and over 60
percent in intensive care have not had
any with kovid have not had any
vaccination at all and there are two
million slots available in the next week
alone so i urge honourable members on
all sides of the house to do everything
possible to encourage your constituents
to get boosted now this is the very best
way to save lives reduce pressure on our
nhs and keep our country open and i
commend this statement to the highest